huit ans l'autre c'est toi qu'a besoin
d'eux il y avait une vanne quoi des cas
ils ont besoin de lui étant moins de 23
ans avait tout le monde a besoin de tout
le monde on est dans un monde où ton
docte ne pas vous pouvez pas vivre
autrement que dans l'envié la jalousie
fait tiquer le toque de jalouser ses
bienfaiteurs de l'humanité qui vous fait
[Applaudissements]
l'aigreur de bernay vu un psy trois fois
pas plus même suffit je vais très vite
et il invite si ma [ __ ] dit en parlant
de toi il m'avait dit que tu me
jalousent est que j'étais une sorte de
modèle et c'est pour ça qui est beau
temps des gros hockey eh ben ça je veux
bien l'entendre les jeunes vont tarifs
aussi
sur lui notamment d'aborder tellement
manoel
il va dire une métier va dire une bêtise
attendez est-ce que vous avez un petit
mot aujourd'hui à venir d'abord oui
d'abord journaliste
il a été rédaction
du parisien c'est comme françois mais
c'est toujours un gros tirage c'est non
il a écrit un bouquin magnifique oui
tu arrives malicieux l'admirer ou
d'admirer avait plus que j'admire tant
il donne des cours de journalisme gmail
être mais je n'ai pas le niveau donc
franchement c'est quelqu'un de bien
c'est dommage que je n'aie pas vos
tarifs
ce
matin que tu sais qu'il n'a pas
détaillées est-ce que tu pensais tout ce
que tu viens de dire je tenais normes
merde
n'ai aucune valeur tarraga
[Musique]
ressemble à l'extérieur l'autre à dire
oui il est d'ailleurs ressort à
l'extérieur oui c'est une phrase de
rocco siffredi
merci en tout cas merci ça m'a fait du
bien merci ah ben ça fait du bien à tout
le monde